c'est sa land où il faut quand même aimé
le piquant et ne pas être aurais je
t'avais pas du tout oui ok c'est bien
que si on veut vraiment piquant au même
moment une charcuterie de la calabre
très peu connue a fait son apparition
sur les tables de certains restaurants
depuis quelques tomes santé à la maison
moins chanceuse ma chambre et oui avec
des pattes sur une bruschetta ou sur une
pizza tous les moyens sont bons pour
déguster une douille à ça donne ainsi un
tic aux assiettes
contrairement à un saucisson qui est
plutôt sec la india a une texture plus
tôt moelleuse c'est comme une pâte et
c'est vraiment ça sympa tu es une
tartinade qui a plus de got sun arrière
goût donc vous pourriez décrire le goût
lundi ya bien un piquant qui va venir
naturellement dupeyron chino mais aussi
un piquant qui vont venir du poivron
rouge qui est plus floral spécialité de
la calabre dans le sud de l'italie
la haine nous ya tire ses origines de la
france et de ces andouilles les boyaux
contenant un mélange d'abba de porc
qu'on laisse fermenter le veulent les
français qui sont dans les années 1800
qui occupait le sud de l'italie
spécifiquement naples et la sicile et la
plupart du sud
donc c'est sûr que cette formule où
cette recette là c'est fait 2 qu'est ce
que aux autres les français faisait mais
n'utilisait qu'est ce qu'il y avait en
main donc à lyon rajouter le picard oui
parce que il y en a partout dans le sud
la calabre est aussi très piquant ce
qu'il reconnut pau le chili et les
oignons rouges les oignons de tropea
vraiment comme classique mais sinon
c'était d abord beaucoup d'abord
différents nous avons
michele fait lui même la haine dooya
qu'il utilise à ses restaurants
aujourd'hui le coeur et le flanc port
ont remplacé les abats enzo de son côté
sert à ses clients une andouille a
importé d'italie par son ami angelo
[Musique]
est ce que vous aimez les picards sinon
laisse tomber parce que c'est assez
difficile mais les gens qui aiment ça
ils veulent juste ça ap là ça c'est un
chat ça devient vraiment comme une belle
texture comme ça un petit peu de laitue
comme ça en c'est la laitue c'est assez
flex aval a fléchi d'un petit peu ça
donne un petit goût un petit peu d'huile
d'olive
sinon on perd l'italianité comment vivre
sans huile d'olive impossible et voilà
et ça c'est la piadina collant d'oeil à
ce que vous entends j'ai encore beaucoup
d'amis en italie aujourd'hui insultes
sur draka lablad tout ça partout c'est
comme dire une baguette en parisien
c'est normal ouais ouais la nuit assez
vraiment maison là bas là ils font
l'effort de tous avec qui font vraiment
beaucoup de choses surtout les pattes
tiers souvent beaucoup de soldes pas
d'aller restera la pizza aussi avec la
douille assez bon pizza m'en serais
landes où il respecte
c'était très bon aussi ici la hinduja
étaient si difficiles à trouver dans les
supermarchés c'est un produit quand même
encore ethniques dans ce sens qu'on le
retrouve surtout dans des boutiques
italienne et c'est aussi un phénomène de
chefs branché c'est quand même un
produit tendance là c'est vraiment cool
de diên douille vidal de l'avoir sur le
menu l'épicerie m'a inspiré quand ils
m'ont appelé
on fait une émission sur la india puis
je me suis dit ok on est dans la côte
amalfitaine du sud de l'italie
on est dans la calabria
donc c'est vraiment une pizza qui
m'inspire lits doubles citron lamente
des oignons rouges donc la [ __ ] sa
alladjan van jets l'épicerie on aimerait
d'art
[Musique]